all right there is a ton I have to talk
to you guys about this week as you
probably know I was in Israel last week
where I was invited to speak at a video
conference the remainder of the week was
spent wandering the streets talking to
people about peace and eating ridiculous
amounts of hummus spending most of my
time in Tel Aviv
I saw people of pretty much every race
color religion ethnicity and nationality
living side by side I heard Hebrew
Arabic English French Spanish Japanese
German and several other languages being
spoken simultaneously in restaurants in
cafes I saw a coexistence in a part of
the world that has very little of it I
also spent a day in Jerusalem if you saw
the video that we posted a couple days
ago I tried to show how close these
religious sites are and give a little
context to an extremely small yet
complex city walking through the Old
City of Jerusalem I explored the Jewish
and Christian quarters and stop for
falafel in the Arab quarter I felt it
was important not just to talk about
these places as we do but actually to
live them as well I exited the old city
at the Damascus Gate where literally a
day before a Jew had been stabbed while
there was no doubt the neighborhood was
tense there was also a feeling that this
was life and life goes on unfortunately
I heard about the San Bernardino
terrorist attacks while on the beach in
Israel I can't really explain to you
guys how incredibly surreal it was to be
so far away from something so horrific
happening 60 miles away from where I
live while I was 7600 miles away from
home
adding to the surreal feeling was that I
was in the epicenter of a country that
deals with terrorism in some form or
another pretty much every day
suddenly I had people asking me what it
was like to be in America with all our
mass shootings the world felt completely
flipped on his head on the 14 hour plane
ride back to Los Angeles I've read
what's left by my guest this week Nick
Cohen Nick is a writer for Time
Spectator the observer and standpoint
his first book what's left is an
absolute must-read if you dig what we do
here though what's left was written in
2007 Nick absolutely nails so much of
the lunacy we've been talking about on
the Left these days from their dishonest
tactics of lying about opponents views
to aligning themselves
people who had just as easily have them
killed he goes on a journey through
history to show how the far left has so
often strengthened the very ideas that
they purport to be against there were so
many passages of the book that I felt
like could have been written today that
it was almost like reading something
from the future
he nailed the regressive left before the
term was even out there speaking of the
regressives you didn't think I was gonna
get through a show without mentioning
them did ya yeah not gonna happen
one of the issues I've called them out
on consistently is that if they don't
stop smearing the Liberals willing to
talk about Islamic extremism that
they're gonna hand our future to the far
right we're seeing this right this very
second across Europe as far-right
parties or winning elections and gaining
in the polls from France to Belgium to
Sweden and more this is clearly coming
to the American shores right now - as
Donald Trump just this week called for
denying Muslims entry into the United
States obviously this is idiotic over
the top and ridiculous
but it can only exist in a climate where
fear of real discussion has been stifled
if we aren't afraid of talking about
Islamism especially the difference
between people and doctrine then we can
finally have an honest conversation
about refugees immigration and
everything else but if we do as the
regressives are doing this very second
by making no distinction between people
who are trying to talk about serious
issues versus people who trade on fear
then we help the real xenophobes and
silenced the Reformers even as a kid I
always loved john f kennedy's famous
quote we have nothing to fear but fear
itself its lofty and big but it hits
something that is extremely human
sometimes fear in things is scarier than
the actual thing itself that's not to
say that radical Islam isn't scary but
we also feed that fear if we don't deal
with it honestly now that we live in a
time when people are incredibly fearful
and much of it is with good reason as
we've seen the spread of an evil
ideology with no signs of letting up
that doesn't mean we have to be afraid
to speak out against it or silence those
who dare to do so actually of course it
means the exact opposite fear is what
they're regressives and the far-right
are both going to use to splinter us
against each other so they can gain
power
the world is in a strange fearful moment
right this very second we can either
give in to our worst impulses or try to
be better I'm pretty sure you guys know
which side I'm gonna choose as we sat in
a packed restaurant in Tel Aviv I asked
a friend how he feels about all the
stabbings without missing a beat he said
we have to keep living we have no choice
I think we could all use a little of
that spirit right now let's not give in
to fear fed to us by terrorists or fear
fed to us by politicians let's keep
fighting because if we don't choice is
exactly what we're gonna give up